across the country
ordinary americans from all walks of
life are taking whatever measures
necessary to prepare i'm preparing my
family for the total destruction of the
power grid the yellowstone super volcano
a financial collapse and protect
themselves and survival's the goal it's
into the spider hole
from what they perceive is the fast
approaching end of the world as we know
it
what i'm gonna use
like this
[Music]
next we go inside the lives of three
committed preppers who have devised
extensive plans these are gonna protect
you from all those nasty germs out there
gone to great lengths come on with your
hands off i will shoot you
and made huge personal sacrifices to
ensure their very survival like the
phrase goes heading to the hills so
that's why we're moving to the mountains
of tennessee are you excited to move no
the experts will assess their extreme
preps and decide if they have what it
takes to face armageddon if i want my
family to survive this is what they're
gonna have to do and to survive yeah i
prefer you don't shoot my dog this is
doomsday preppers
martin coville is a retired police
officer who now makes his living as one
of america's two million big rig truck
drivers
i see much of the united states as an
over-the-road truck breaker breaker 19
radio check police and i love doing that
you get to see parts of the country that
most people don't normally see with his
wife sarah at his side and the couple's
two miniature dachshunds on the dash
martin spends 10 months of the year
working the open road hauling over 750
tons of goods and traveling 100 000
miles
in driving around
i look at what we've built
much of it is grandiose
wonderful to look at
but i also worry that it's extremely
fragile
what do you want
i'm preparing to survive the next great
depression caused by a worldwide
economic collapse
i'm very afraid that
as soon as maybe three years
maybe five at the outmost
a very very terrible time in our
nation's history this coming
with the nation of china holding the
majority of our debt if they decide to
call that in
the united states will collapse
economically
within a week you'll see chaos rain
major metropolitan areas
will become a death trap the majority of
people will try to get out
and when they do they will clog major
arteries martin is all too aware that
without the 5.5 billion tons of
deliveries made from trucks like his
grocery stores would be empty within
three days
trucks that bring the items to the
grocery stores or the warehouses or even
in your home are going to be stopped
they're abandoned facing dangers from
marauding bands pirates
it could be disastrous beyond measure
compared to anything that we've ever
experienced
without trucks america stops
throughout this apocalyptic future
martin is determined not just to keep
making his deliveries but also to help
other truckers make theirs
side my long-term goal is help america
become the nation that it should be
again
and the biggest way that i can do that
is make a delivery
in a safe and timely manner
if i can help other drivers
survive
then our nation is going to be able to
rebuild itself
with truckers
we have a chance
[Music]
after the 2008 economic crash martin and
sarah were among the many millions of
americans who lost their home to
foreclosure their big rig truck was all
they had left
hey welcome to our home they now live
and prep out of its 53 square foot
sleeper cab the size of most americans
master closet since our home is mobile
we can't carry as much as you might
store at your own home
i've got stuff stashed just about
everywhere i can stash it in here a
little bit of dog food
after the collapse
there's not going to be factories
i'm going to be able to make clothes
couldn't make a shirt for marty out of
the camel i have a stash of
dry food and i have two layers of it
behind this cabinet
dehydrated food not only lasts longer it
is two to four times lighter than
fresher can supplies making it an ideal
food source for the mobile prepper
this is celery
we have approximately four to six months
worth of food in the truck
but sarah and martin are not just
stockpiling food supplies
about seven years ago sarah was
diagnosed with a very rare type of
cancer
being a mobile prepper
it's made things
a little different than if you're
dealing with
non-ill people
we stock up on our prescription meds by
maybe skipping a day or two a month
eventually they will run out as a
prepper you can only prepare so much
i'm gonna be one sick little cookie if
if i don't have my meds
she's one of the biggest fighters that i
know of and she
said i promised you 50 years and we've
got 25 in
do they have one of them are you
oh immensely immensely okay we're sure
trying
martin and sarah face an uncertain
future but they're doing everything they
can to prepare
you have to have some plan of
surviving out here
they have created a network of supply
caches all around the country from new
mexico and kentucky to seattle
we have to get somewhere where we at
least have some type of safe zone
the biggest problem will be the lack of
fuel
if martin's fear is correct an economic
collapse will cause hyperinflation and
food and gas prices will skyrocket
if currency inflated
by over 1300 percent what used to be
say a dollar for us
you'd need 1300 of those for the same
buying power for gas diesel martin's gas
tank holds 180 gallons enough fuel to
take him just over 1 000 miles but in a
crisis he believes that will not be
enough
i have the ability to siphon from
abandoned vehicles
technically that would be stealing but
we're talking about in a total collapse
people aren't going to be worried about
that
for a mobile prepper keeping moving in a
doomsday situation is of the utmost
importance but martin and sarah realize
they will eventually need to rest which
could effectively turn their 53-foot
truck into a sitting duck in a total
collapse situation rotting gangs are
going to be looking for anything they
can get a hold of
i need to
keep my vehicles as safe as possible and
away from prying eyes
excuse me i drive an 18-wheeler big rig
and i'm looking for something like
some type of camouflage to hide your
truck yeah yeah definitely come around
this way i'll take you to it okay thanks
in recent years hunting and fishing
stores like this one in albuquerque new
mexico have become go-to mega stores for
the prepper community
and products originally designed for the
sportsmen are now being used in new ways
military camo netting ooh
i didn't know that you could get it in
the civilian world it might take three
but we could cover your truck more 3d
like this gonna give you more of that 3d
image so this is going to be the way to
go we're seriously trying to conceal
something what exactly are you gonna be
using all this stuff for i travel around
the country i'm an over-the-road truck
driver i'm also what you call a prepper
i want to survive and my rig to survive
so i can be part of the rebuilding
process i know it sounds corny but it's
my lifestyle now yeah
need something for my
uh bug out bag i got back got to have it
do you have one oh yeah
i have a 3300 cubic inch ready to go got
some food ammo guns 1911. just in case
why are you ready then hey it's all
gonna hit the fan sometime
good sir how about yourself pretty good
find everything all right oh i found
more come together
see 422.55 okay
making a 105 000 pound truck disappear
is more than a one-man job
so martin has called upon the assistance
of an expert to help him execute his
plan
my little brother who is actually bigger
than i am
we call him red
red is retired from the air force
he's worked all around the world
in different situations many he can't
talk about you're backed in pretty good
with uh concealment
he taught me many good things about what
i need to look at as a mobile prepper
the craps hit the fan already he needs
to get off the road it's getting late he
needs to secure the vehicle the main
objective is to conceal from the roadway
and so we're going to set up some
camouflage netting
over the front and the sides that are
exposed to any kind of roadway traffic
to mix in with the local foliage
camouflage works by tricking the eye
into perceiving color patterns as
familiar objects such as trees fallen
leaves or other natural surroundings
this optical illusion allows even large
items to hide in plain sight you're
gonna need a lot more than just three
rolls to do this you're gonna need about
10 to 15 rolls
a thousand to fifteen hundred dollars
just to camo this thing pros good
concealment you're at least able to
secure your load con
you got 1500 invested bounce that off
your list of other priorities that you
have
once the rig is concealed martin doesn't
plan on sheltering inside
he's prepared to leave sarah and the
dogs to patrol the perimeter and defend
what's his with a little help from his
rolling arsenal part of my personal
armament that i carry in the truck is a
louisville slugger thank you madam a
side handle baton the straight baton 45
caliber carbine
i personally carry a concealed weapon
everywhere that i'm legally allowed to
i haven't been able to find a bazooka
that fits in my cab though
with these weapons you'll be much
safer on the road and you'll be able to
help other people
my name martin means warrior or warlike
i am a very warlike individual i try and
fight for what's right i don't like
beliefs
my greatest fear
upon a total economic societal collapse
is that i won't be able to protect my
wife
when you're dealing with somebody
who's extremely ill sarah has tried to
say
you should just leave me and go on
because you can survive you know that i
won't
and of course i've told her that's not
going to happen because that's not what
i do
i think i'm more afraid of my cancer
than i am
of the economic downfall but i think
it's a very strong possibility
sarah and martin already face many
challenges but they fear that an even
more uncertain future lies ahead come on
with your hands up
retired police officer and trucker
martin colville fears a catastrophic
economic collapse will unleash anarchy
on america's highways what we're looking
at is a total meltdown of
society as we know it it's gonna be so
scary
but it's not just desperate civilians
he's worried about he believes that his
truck full of goods will come under
attack from a far more sinister force
something that most people don't think
about modern prisons use electronic
locks when the grid goes down
electricity is no longer around
prisons around the nation will simply
open up
all of a sudden you're gonna have a
flood of
angry men and women
and they're gonna come flooding out
america's prison population is roughly
equal to its number of truckers 2
million
if social chaos leads to prison breaks
martin believes he and his comrades may
be overrun
i've dealt with them i've arrested them
i fought with them
i've survived and they'll want payback
but years in law enforcement may not be
enough to help martin navigate a road
teaming with violent criminals
today he has asked red to devise the
ultimate test of his mobile prepper
skills
you have to charge around after every
shot
when it hits the fan he's going to have
a lot of different obstacles people are
going to see an 18-wheeler and they're
going to want what's in that 18-wheeler
traveling fully loaded at 65 miles per
hour martin's 105 000-pound truck is
bigger and faster than a military tank
but with a 53-foot trailer and a wide
turning radius it would take only two
cars parked in a narrow roadway to stop
him in his tracks
today we have truck hijackings that do
occur and we still have an economy that
is
existing
in a total economic collapse it's just
going to escalate
in 2009 alone 859 truckloads worth
almost half a billion dollars were
hijacked on american roads as a police
officer i was trained to visualize
scenarios and that's how i survived some
of the more
scary moments of my life and that way
it's just another weapon that's kind of
pointed at marty being shot being
stabbed i've used that in my prepping
lifestyle the colville brothers will
meet on a stretch of new mexico back
road where unbeknownst to martin red has
set a trap
this ambush is designed to expose not
just the defensive liabilities of
martin's vehicle but a more personal
weakness as well
now that we're actually doing this
hands-on exercise
he can better realize what he needs to
do and then also for sarah and she'll
better understand her role to protect
marty and them as a team whenever marty
dismounts the vehicle you're going to be
providing that overwatch protection
somebody returns fire towards the truck
you need to be able to duck down take
cover
and then pop back up gonna defend us
with the knitting needle
so you'll yell left right or whatever
left
if you see somebody at the left we don't
know where bad guys will come from
that's part of the the fun of the
training
yeah i prefer you don't shoot my dog
[Music]
[Applause]
close the door so i can see if there's
anybody coming yell out if you see
something
keep an eye on him
see if you see anybody move
[Music]
are you injured
my leg
help me you behind the jeep i can see
your feet come on with your hands up
on the ground
back off back off put your weapon on the
deck
back up
lay down i will shoot you
right up right arrow down on the ground
[Music]
i'm just trying to help that's wide out
arms straight
spread your legs
i was just trying to help somebody okay
oh my goodness
my adrenaline is just pumping big time
okay
i felt just like if it had really
happened
tactically sound you checked your right
you checked your left you spotted byron
sitting behind the jeep once she draws
you into the zone jason came around from
from your left sarah was trying to alert
you of that but then again she was
moaning and of course you're gonna she's
gonna draw you into the zone so what
should i have done the minute you see
somebody there back away my natural
instinct is damsel in distress
i knew that so they played on
your heart
to kind of come in here that's something
i've got to work on because i'm just so
geared to there's somebody hurt there's
somebody hurt it's a deficiency that
you've identified post collapse hey it's
you it's sarah getting to your safe
haven
thank you little brother not a problem
man i appreciate it
very very much
[Music]
a lot of it is left up to us what
choices we make
when i see someone in need or someone
being bullied
i will step in and say no
and if it means taking a risk
there are those of us that are willing
to do that
all that evil needs to propagate is for
good men to do nothing
martin the expert's practical preppers
commend you for taking on the challenge
of being a mobile prepper however while
you have a well-stocked fuel supply it
will eventually run out leaving you
stranded on the road it is recommended
that you secure some trading items which
you can use to barter for fuel
it makes a lot of sense i definitely
wouldn't want to have them as an
addition to your security preparations
we also recommend you invest in 360
degree motion detectors they will alert
you and sarah if anyone approaches your
truck that makes a lot of sense i i
honestly haven't thought about that i
will look into that
since national geographic filmed the
boys and i
we've done what we normally do pick up
and deliver freight all of my trucker
friends out there
please
i want you to be around for as long as
you can
and so that we can help get this great
country of ours
back on its feet
while hyperinflation and severe
depressions have occurred in major
economies in the past economists do not
believe the united states is currently
at risk of such disasters
donna nash is determined to save her
family from a worldwide pandemic we've
been outside so let's make sure that we
are clean okay but will keeping an
immaculately clean house be enough to
give her the upper hand over her
greatest fear
donna nash lives in the picturesque
mountain town of alpine utah
30 miles outside salt lake city
like many suburban moms donna likes to
keep a clean house
but it's not because she's expecting
company
i am preparing for a worldwide pandemic
go go go go go
before i was prepared for pandemic
i was probably spending
20 hours a day worrying about it
when the pandemic comes
those who are prepared
will survive
those who do not prepare
will die
a pandemic is a virus or disease that
infects large numbers of people in
multiple countries
a pandemic can happen in a matter of
hours
if someone on one side of the country
had the disease and they flew across the
country by the time they get to the
other side people are taking it home
they're taking it to work
a 2010 study suggests that the risk of
disease transmission during
transcontinental flights is high making
it possible for one sick person to cause
simultaneous outbreaks in multiple
geographic locations
i am most afraid of the flu because it's
so common
that people don't really take it
seriously
and that has killed
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people
the world health organization believes
that a devastating influenza pandemic is
almost inevitable even conservative
estimates suggest as many as 100 million
people worldwide may be infected and
millions will die
my worst fear is that i would somehow
contract the pandemic we've been outside
so let's make sure that we are clean
okay
and bring it home to my family and then
have one of my family members die
[Music]
sorry that really got me
now i have to stop
i need bouffant caps i want 2 000. no no
no i want no i want three thousand the
flu is transmitted through droplets in
the air meaning catching a deadly virus
can be as simple as being on the wrong
end of a sneeze okay how soon can you
get those to me
[Laughter]
maybe
so donna has stockpiled thousands of
protective masks and gloves in her
garage
i put together kits that have everything
you would need to survive a pandemic
in my kits i have
isolation gowns
antiviral tissues exam gloves n95 mask
foot covers heavy duty sanitizer
goggles
steramine antibacterial wipes and hair
covers
when an influenza pandemic outbreak
occurs the cdc estimates that it could
last for up to eight weeks
our world when a pandemic hits will look
very different
if people do have to be out in public
they'll be wearing masks
train stations subway stations may shut
down
because of the fear of
contracting the disease
but risk or no risk donna's mission is
to make her whole community a germ-free
bubble
my plan would be to
help my immediate neighbors if they have
the things they need
they will be protected which will in
turn protect us
and donna sees no harm in starting early
some neighborhoods have the avon lady
this neighborhood has the pandemic lady
i give my kits to my neighbors my
community anyone who i can convince
to take one hi i'm donna nash bob and
bonnie's daughter i brought something i
wanted to show you when i first knock on
someone's door they're usually a little
skeptical but by the time i have
explained come on in they're convinced
i've always enjoyed taking care of
people right here yeah that'll be great
it has gotten a little more
intense
sonia
there is going to be a pandemic and it
will be bad i've been putting together
these pandemic kits and giving them to
those who i think would appreciate them
jack i think you need to hear about this
we have n95 masks
for infectious disease okay
the second most critical thing will be
your gloves if you shake hands with
someone who just sneezed into their hand
you're in trouble you will absolutely
need to have hand sanitizer i've never
even thought of anything like that have
you
it truly is a matter of life and death
well it's kind of scary when you think
about it
it is scary the question is will you be
prepared
you know when we opened the door check i
i didn't
think that's what we were going to get
and i hoped he was bringing a goodie to
eat something like a pie
when a pandemic happens
every countertop will be sanitized
our clothes our linens everything will
be
washed and dried on hot cycles so that
any form of
contamination will be killed
we will do our very best to have
everything be clean
but will donna be ready to do what's
necessary if one of her family members
becomes infected
donna nash is scared that will soon be
faced with a catastrophic global
pandemic
she knows that when disaster strikes
being prepared could make the difference
between life and death
today donna's having sunday dinner with
her family
but she's also got an extra group
activity on the agenda i'm going to take
advantage of my family who's all here
and do a pandemic drill which they
probably won't like but if i want my
family to survive they're gonna have to
learn to like it and that's just all
there is to it
okay guys
we
are gonna do a pandemic drill
i would like to watch a ball game i know
you do i know you do but i'm gonna
interrupt you because i want you to do
this it's really that important if you
go into labor just raise your hand okay
it's important for my family to
understand what they need to do during a
pandemic so these are the isolation
gowns
so
i want them to participate in drills
these can you tell what they are
not hats
feet thingies yep i'm gonna give you all
a mask and the last thing we're gonna
give you are the gloves do we really
need to put them on yes you really do
doctors believe that the young may not
have immunity to a serious flu virus and
therefore will be at a greater risk of
infection
on your mark get set go
every prepper knows that time is crucial
in a survival situation
so donna's goal is to get her family
geared up in their isolation suits as
quickly as possible you're like the only
kids in the whole universe that are
gonna know how to do this
during the pandemic there's not gonna be
any room for error how are we doing
terrible oh keep going dad you could do
it
dave you are not taking this seriously
okay guys we're gonna go out to the
front lawn okay let's go come on
go fast fast fast fast fast in a real
pandemic donna's family would have to
wear these suits every time they went
outside so they could protect their
clothing from germs
let's go everybody go
hurry dad don't push
good job everyone good job
[Music]
it's like quite an operation
if i saw someone dressed in this stuff i
would think in my head what are they
doing
once the garments are exposed to the
outside world they must be removed again
before re-entering the sanitized house
in order to avoid the spread of
potentially deadly germs you're gonna
try not to touch anything because your
hands are now clean all right take your
shoe covers off then you're gonna take
your hats off then we're gonna give you
hand sanitizer good job
ah so deborah's at the door can she come
in
but when her daughter-in-law deborah
turns up late for the drill donna has
the perfect chance to test out another
potentially life-saving pandemic prep
quarantine
ah we're having our drill you're out in
the pandemic world you're contaminated
during a pandemic isolating patients to
avoid the spread of infection is
standard procedure
and family or not donna has no qualms
about doing just that
in fact she has 4 000 feet of plastic
sheeting ready and waiting now that we
have a contaminated person we have to
seal off this area so we want you on
this side because this will be the safe
space we'll have all of you come on out
if one of my
family members became infected
it would be very hard
to seal them off in a room
but on the other hand i have to protect
everyone in the family
this will teach you to be late for
dinner come on in gonna have you take
your coat off and your shoes off
if anyone in the family wants to go in
to see them
they will
have to put on all of the protective
gear before they're allowed to go in
nice rebooting
does grandma look funny
colton does not want to be quarantined
my family often thinks i'm a little
crazy with how much i do
looks great
but my job at the end of the day is to
make sure all my family survives
right down to my little grandbabies dear
heavenly father we're very grateful for
this food we ask you to bless it that it
will nourish us and give us the strength
that we need amen amen
i know i'm here to help people i love
those shells
without a doubt i am
supposed to help people get prepared
donna the experts suggest that even if
there is not a pandemic in your area
your general preparations will leave you
ready for other catastrophes and should
give you peace of mind
however during a pandemic you need an
alternate location where you can take
shelter for at least eight weeks
i don't feel like i have to have some
bunker
to
hide out in during a pandemic i feel
like my home is completely adequate and
i'm comfortable with that
since national geographic was here our
family has increased our security for
our home and the demand for pandemic
kids has drastically increased and so
that's kept me pretty busy
but i really look forward to another
year of helping people get better
prepared
the world health organization says that
influenza pandemics can cause severe
social economic and political stress as
has been shown historically but while it
is likely that a pandemic will occur in
our future it is impossible to predict
the severity and timing of such an event
kevin o'brien believes his home state is
in danger of being washed away
completely so he is making the move to
higher ground whether his family is on
board or not are you excited to move no
kevin o'brien is a restaurant manager
who lives in jacksonville florida with
his wife and four kids
like many families kevin and his wife
amy are making a big change and moving
out of their home state two three
i've lived in jacksonville since i was
seven years old
it's definitely home so it wasn't an
easy decision to kind of pick up and
move
but they're not moving in pursuit of a
job opportunity
the o'briens are attempting to escape
the end of the world
i think i owe to my family to do
everything i can to keep them safe and
out of harm's way
i spent six to eight months researching
where would be the best place in the
united states and moved
and then we spent another two and a half
years trying to find the right piece of
property
what i consider myself obsessed with it
i spend a lot of time at it until we're
out of florida gonna be on the forefront
of my mind
kevin believes that a 2012 polar shift
will cause the earth to move off its
axis resulting in an onslaught of
natural disasters when the earth shifts
on its axis for instance florida can go
from being you know close to the equator
to much further up north possibly where
alaska is
pole shifts have happened over the last
200 million years we know there's been a
pole shift greater than 30 degrees when
the polar shift happens we're going to
see rising sea levels earthquakes
volcanoes
tsunamis bouncing off coasts back and
forth entire countries might be
underwater
and since florida is a low-lying coastal
peninsula kevin believes that his home
state will be completely devastated by a
polar shift
40 miles inland an hour from the beach
in florida we're still only 20 feet 28
feet above sea level so if there's a
polar shift nice chunk of florida might
very well be underwater or close to it
it really has a low survivability rate
so kevin and his wife amy are uprooting
their entire family from the only home
they have ever known a lot of scary
stuff on the horizon that little bitty
square is that uh what is it a 30 by 60
foot drive-through barn like the phrase
goes heading to the hills
so that's why we're moving to the
mountains of tennessee
[Music]
it's kind of cool you can see the frost
on the ground where the sun hasn't
broken through and you can see down
around the property
kevin has bought a plot of land 540
miles from his current home at an
elevation of 1800 feet
far enough away from the coast to rule
out tsunamis and rising sea levels the
appalachian mountains are the oldest
mountain chain in the world
it's geologically stable because it's
extremely thick rock the o'brien's
picked out their home site with slightly
different criteria in mind than the
average american
we're all a little too dependent on our
government we're too dependent on uh our
local grocery stores yeah i think that's
definitely the better location over
there our land is secure and defendable
there's a forest and timber there for
firewood we can grow our own vegetables
there there's a source of water we can
raise our own livestock there my sheep
are going right here
and my goats are going right here you're
not having any goats you're not having
any sheep
so we'll settle for cattle and chickens
with their land purchased the o'briens
are beginning to build their apocalyptic
dream home
and while kevin is all for a traditional
underground bunker amy is putting her
foot down could you see our moms if we
built a house out of soda cans they
would just freak out
my wife doesn't want to live in anything
that looks like a bunker and i can't
blame her look at this one isn't that
cool bunker or no bunker the o'briens
will not be building your regular house
with a white picket fence we'd like to
build a really solid home probably out
of reinforced concrete bulletproof
waterproof fireproof
earthquake proof and ultimately pole
shift proof are you excited to move no
well are you excited to get a new house
no
are you excited
yeah
amy and i have uh sat down and we've
we've explained to them you know why
we're moving and they they pretty much
understand it in other ways you know
they're going to miss their family and
friends
it'll be nice and safe up there it'll be
you know uh mountains all around us and
we'll be way far away from all the city
life and the drama
moving across the country is difficult
enough for any family
but as preppers the o'briens face a
couple of extra steps
the family has two thousand pounds of
food preps that will also be making the
nine hour journey to tennessee all right
here we go who ordered the rice
but we probably have
five six hundred pounds of rice now
i will hold the bottle in the funnel and
you can scoop the rice and pour it in
oh good job in a post-apocalyptic world
these dry staples will help supplement
the food they can grow themselves in
tennessee
are you gonna help us
we feel we're about a year's worth of
food now and and the goal is to really
have two three four years cap it off
that's the last one we're all done with
the rice
if much of the earth is rattled with
devastating natural disasters kevin
wants his family to prepare for broken
gas pipes and downed power lines
so he's packing up some energy
alternatives that can heat and power his
new home independently
there is the primitive home heater made
from pickle barrels filled with water
the pickle barrels are black and you can
fill them up with water and uh stick
them in a greenhouse
during the colder winter months they
absorb the heat of the sun all day
at night they release the heat so
they're basically a solar battery
and 10 solar panels which will provide
the family with 2 350 watts of power and
peak sunlight
enough to provide electric light and
refrigeration we've actually managed to
buy 10 solar panels once we get up to
the property and build the house there
we should have enough power to power our
everyday needs
if much of the country is without
electricity and access to food and water
is limited kevin expects what we know is
normal life to crumble
this is just the newest home defense
accessory that uh i have purchased this
is 20 rounds
society uh would just be upended the
possibility is just mind-boggling people
are going to know that we're going to
have food so i think security and
defense is going to be an issue
we're getting ready to load these onto
the trailer so i'll need your help
loading these also i don't want you know
i don't want the kids you know helping
us load these so just you and i can load
these right in readiness for the big
move kevin has built up a cache of
weapons and 5 000 rounds of ammo that
will allow his family to defend their
new homestead shot them before he so you
know you know firsthand they're not
something to be taken lightly we'll
create our own little uh firing range
and keep our firearm skills up to snuff
there's some pretty decent-sized bullets
it can definitely do some damage and put
a hurting or kill somebody make sure no
one's playing with these
thank you
sir
the time for kevin and amy o'brien to
bug out of coastal florida is fast
approaching and they cannot wait we're
really looking forward to starting that
next chapter in our life but are their
kids so enthusiastic are you looking
forward to moving at all no
[Music]
fearing a catastrophic polar shift kevin
o'brien and his wife amy feel that the
only way to safeguard their children is
to bug out to higher ground rebuild that
dam and
increase the size of that pond to a
small lake so they're uprooting their
family to the hills of tennessee
i think this was your first little tiny
tea set
so that was your first one
but kevin's teenage daughter haley isn't
convinced that the move is in her best
interest
are you looking forward to moving at all
no
not at all no
why don't you want to move
my friends
i don't want to leave in the middle of
the school year
it is hard to move in middle school here
i rest my keys
just getting into the teen years so uh
you know doesn't want to uproot and uh
leave her friends behind so you think we
should stay here forever yeah
so let's say
water rises
we're
bobbing
like
bowling pens
then you would think it would have been
good to move
a lot of our family thinks we're crazy
a lot of our friends think we're crazy
well we are crazy
when the pole shift happens we're gonna
be the ones who are fine and they're
going to be the ones without
after years of preparation the day of
the big move has
arrived
mama
because of all of their prepper goods
kevin and his family are moving more
than two extra tons of food ammo and
energy preps
fuel alone will cost them over one
thousand dollars
i'm gonna miss jacksonville area and
family and friends hugs
we have a neighbor that has the same
concerns as we do we've been neighbors
for
seven years
i'm gonna cry
the polar shift is happening i don't
necessarily think it's the end of the
world
but i think the people who aren't
prepared
it's the end of the world for them
it is a nine hour drive
this has been a goal for so long but
it's
kind of sad to leave
[Music]
we're really going to be looking forward
to uh to a new life
hey babe hey go ahead
are we there yet
uh that's a negative
there's gonna be two sides of the fence
the halves and the have-nots and i
prefer to see my family on the side of
the halves
kevin the experts have determined that
your purchase of 130 acres of land in
tennessee will provide you with an
abundance of resources and allow you to
become self-sustainable however two
lines of defense close to your main
homestead will be essential for your
family's survival we're gonna start off
by getting watchdogs but we will also be
putting in other defenses
okay haley so how do you feel about
being here now that we're here now that
we're here
i'll say that i do like it
um
i have adjusted to school better than i
thought i would
and i'll say that the entire experience
i feel has brought in our family
closer together i do like it better than
i thought i would
there is some scientific evidence that a
true polar shift occurred 800 million
years ago when the earth's land masses
formed a supercontinent but scientists
believe that because our continents are
now separated such an event is almost
geologically impossible
[Music]
you